[Music]
thank you
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to illuminate some of
those amazing 1.5s for you all out there
but before we dive in I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca bekonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission so 1.5s are among
some of my favorite POI tricks in fact
they were the POI tricks that I started
this very Channel with and now there's a
lot of variations of them out there I
even did an entire series talking about
how deep the rabbit hole is with these
tricks and the many other tricks that
are related to them I'll go ahead and
link to that down in the description as
well as up in the cards if you're
watching on YouTube but for today's
purposes I wanted to keep things classic
some of these may look familiar some of
them you may be seeing for the first
time but I guarantee you all of them are
really cool and involve doing one loop
with the POI as well as a pendulum so
let's get it started first up in
absolute classic the 1.5 beat weave or
as they were originally called the one
and a half beat weave fun fact because
originally YouTube's text entry system
for its titles didn't allow us to put in
the characters for one half we had to
use 1.5 as a placeholder instead and
well because that was the title of every
video that featured one and a halfs we
just started calling the 1.5s instead
funny way that YouTube has influenced
POI nomenclature right either which way
the original is still amazing
foreign next up the second 1.5 I ever
learned that's right the 1.5 butterfly
there's been some controversy over the
years as to whether or not this actually
qualifies as a butterfly which for the
record I still think that it does but
either way you can look at this as a
great way to explore 1.5 in wall plane
and create really cool moments where the
POI seem to be going straight past each
other
[Music]
all right now for those of us who enjoy
reaching our arms into uncomfortable
places there's the behind the back 1.5
beat weave this was actually featured in
one of the First videos I ever did back
in the day I'm not going to say that I
enjoy this one particularly but it's one
of those that I've run across many many
times since and everybody who has come
about it independently agrees that it is
a great use for these techniques
[Music]
thank you
next up there's the hands together
version of the 1.5 beat weave I've
always enjoyed this because it involves
that cool underhand reach with whichever
hand is doing the spinner at any given
point this is one of the first
variations I ever learned and still one
that I think looks really really cool
plus which it makes for some great
transitions
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally A variation that I learned
from watching an old Ronin video this is
the 1.5 beat weave but performed in such
a way that you're taking the pendulum
around your head instead of just at your
side not only is this a really cool and
kind of quasi-body tracery kind of way
to do a 1.5 but it also leads into some
of my favorite transitions including
dropping into crossers
[Music]
so there you have it those are some of
my favorite 1.5 variations what are some
of yours leave me a comment and let me
know did you get anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find it and of course to help my channel
grow
this video would not be possible were
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible so thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently supporters but you'd
like to become supporters you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
some of the many videos that I have done
on 1.5 I will include a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well either way thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace